amy santiago
teddy oh my god
it's been so long what are you doing
here i'm with the a2 now we're paired
with you today yeah quick 1054 l
ambulance case severed limb
what is going on here uh teddy and i met
at code camp it was a voluntary
refresher course on police codes
some long nights of intense memorizing
it was pretty dope
sounds dope nice to meet you nice to
meet you well i'm gonna go sign in but
we should catch up later yeah great
seeing you you too
who's that guy
uh that was teddy we went on like five
dates last year i liked him but he was
stationed out in queens so i never got
to see him and sort of fizzled right
that's the guy you said the lame stuff
about like he's a good listener i'm
sorry what do you look for in a guy i
don't know real stuff
shape of his ass
before i forget try to be in the lobby
in about a half an hour i got you a
little surprise no
your surprises are always terrible
what's going on you have to tell me
you're gonna love this
remember how you said that teddy would
never be so romantic as to turn a work
trip upstate into a lover's retreat to
the country oh no oh yes i called him
before we left he's on his way here now
uh uh you're welcome
jake
i don't want to see teddy right now i'm
about to break up with him oh
no
when we first started dating amy and i
found this really nice b b over the
poconos we got that sweet city employee
discount remember that babe
teddy think fast drink menu oh
i'm sorry man chuck that right at you i
just thought you really wanted a drink
oh i never need a drink menu i got the
thrills for the pills
cause i'm a pilsner man oh i hadn't
heard that's it
i can't stop myself jericho jericho
jericho
now that's pulling out all the stops
what's going on
i want to break it up
us i want to break us up
hey folks welcome to the maple drip inn
everyone excited to be here we having a
good time
we are not
the main reason you want to break up
with me is the pilsners
i i like other drinks
it's delicious i want more it's not just
the pilsners there are so many reasons i
want to break up that sounded bad didn't
it as a lawyer it's my duty to tell you
to shh okay look
there's just no
spark between us that's vague uh
you're
boring guava juice mango juice orange
juice of course grapefruit juice and
cranberry juice jazz brunch sounds
insane
but should we talk about how efficient
and well-run the nine-nine is for a
while we've got plenty of time for that
i'm gonna hit the little boy's room when
i get back remind me to tell you all
about the omelette bar station we will
spoiler alert two kinds of bell pepper
[Laughter]
oh my god he's so boring he's so bored
the most boring man in america and
that's him trying to be interesting that
is spring break teddy how did you ever
date him oh no
he has a really big wiener doesn't he
wait don't tell me if that's true unless
it's not no but then if you don't say
anything i'll know that it is oh why
don't you say anything about his wiener
amy jake stop stop stop i don't want to
hear about your ex's weiner just you're
not making me feel better why would you
do this to me jake stop spiraling every
time you shake me i see it flopping
around stop oh look there's our gang
leader
seriously
wow
perfect timing successful stakeout
there's no way that sergeant boring big
waiter will shut us down now whoosh i
think i hear teddy you didn't answer got
the old bonester i like to go through my
contacts while i go pee so you only need
to use one hand that's great oh look it
was still recording like recording
recording yeah
oh this is bad what what's wrong
oh my god i was recording the whole time
we said all that bad stuff sorry i was
so preoccupied with the wiener stuff oh
this is bad but while i have you just
stop me
that was fun we're really good at fake
fighting and you were amazing at coming
up with all that stuff to be mad about
yep totally i just said all that stuff
to save the precinct and that's all
oh my god you don't actually care about
my sneakers no
i care about them deeply they're all so
different
okay
hey guys it's teddy from jazz brunch hey
teddy it's teddy from jazz brunch why is
he here i don't know but the fake
fight's back on so shunning your big
mouth [ __ ] and your stupid sneakers you
don't like my shoes you can just tell me
hi
can i talk to you guys about something
actually teddy this is not a good time
we're still having a pretty big fight
well i think what i'm about to say
myself things
amy i'm still in love with you what what
what oh
i'll skip his cup scoop this is super
uncomfortable
jazz
okay okay everybody just calm down and
take a deep breath
what the hell is going on man yeah what
the hell is going on you got a
girlfriend i know and she's fine
thanks sorry i was really planning on
you being in the cab during this okay
that wouldn't make it better maybe i'm
just i'm not over you yet and i would
have never said anything because i
thought you and jake were happy but
after seeing a jazz brunch i think i
might have been wrong don't read into
that that was a freak argument we are
very happy amy we have all the same
interests we have so much chemistry when
we're together it's like no matter where
we are in san diego i feel compelled to
tell you that san diego's terrible lay
it all in the line
amy santiago
will you marry me what okay really could
you stay in the cab i'm sorry i'll be
right there i promise or maybe i won't
what's your answer teddy i don't want to
be with you but you want to be with him
you guys have nothing in common oh yeah
tell that to william atherton the man we
both considered to be the second best
die-hard villain oh she meant it and
also yes we are different people but i
love that about us i love that jake's a
little messy and that he cares so much
about his dumb sneakers and he doesn't
get stressed out about calendars or
flossing my teeth no the non-flossing is
crazy copy that and i love you i'm just
so confused your fight was like
something out of a movie
teddy
i have to tell you the truth no amy is
dying she has one month to live marrying
her would be a waste of time
jake and i were only pretending to fight
so that we could destroy your phone
while we were on the stakeout and you
were in the bathroom we said you were
the most boring man in america and your
phone recorded it i'm sorry we didn't
want you to get mad at us and fail the
precinct wow
you guys are the worst who would do
something like this well i clearly have
an arch nemesis
finally must be someone i put away who's
hell-bent on revenge he's probably gonna
make me choose between saving the city
and saving the woman i love little does
he know i can save both
how are you so calm right now someone is
trying to blow us up i'm calm because
there's not really a bomb i mean if
you're trying to kill someone you don't
call and give them a heads up so they're
just trying to scare us yeah but it
doesn't matter the bomb squad's on their
way they'll do a quick sweep find
nothing and split and this will just
become a funny story we work into our
vows amy there was a bomb at this
wedding your butt your butt is the bomb
please don't say that during the
ceremony is it that you don't like
wordplay or you don't want me to talk
about your butt at all because one of
those notes is really gonna pull through
how did this guy even find out about the
wedding
the stupid engagement announcement
charles put in the paper it had the time
and location of the ceremony amy be very
careful about throwing around
accusations like that because if you're
trying to say i somehow ruined jake's
wedding then i'm gonna kill myself
so tread
lightly okay just take it easy charles
nothing is ruined
see the bomb squad is already here and
they brought a robot this is exactly how
i imagined my wedding would be when i
was a kid well well well
amy santiago amy look your ex-boyfriend
is here on our wedding day why this is
my crew yeah you called me boring so i
leveled up my cool and now i run the
bomb squad i also started traveling i
went to belgium they have the best
spaghetti teddy let's get everything out
on the table here last time we saw you
you kind of proposed to amy so you're
not still in love with her right no i
definitely am my therapist told me to
stop trying to get over it oh weird you
wouldn't hide it even for your own pride
but seriously don't worry i'm a cop i
have a job to do and i'm gonna do it
professionally that's great i'm happy to
hear that meaning i will be doing a
super thorough sweeping of the building
it's gonna take hours so you should
probably just cancel the wedding anyway
congrats you two wow five hours this is
the most exciting contest we've had of
course the incident last year was
exciting but we all know how that ended
no we don't right because of the gag
order
are you sure you want to keep doing this
rosa you really don't have to my feet
hurt a little but i can go as long as it
takes well we're having a great time
back here i'll just tell my buddy ready
to hear about this great salsa that i
make it's so mild you barely taste it
that's it i can't take any more i'm out
bye reggie i'll send you that article
about mailboxes please don't oh my god
teddy is boring people out of the
competition and he doesn't even realize
it
can't let him get to you rosa it's fine
i can handle boring we're friends ooh
guys you will never believe who i saw at
busch gardens last summer
my neighbor yeah just walking around
rosa i can't believe you're still here i
can't believe teddy looks so normal i'm
gonna win you that snoop slog snap
whatever my brain is broken i haven't
slept in 72 hours you've only been doing
the competition for one night i mean
you're allowed to not sleep for other
reasons okay
i got you a coffee oh thank you just
need to put my left hand on the stroller
my right hand grabs the cup my mouth
dude is sipping what's happening my
broken brain won't talk to my body so
i'm doing it bling rosa you don't have
to do this you can stop snarling amy oh
teddy and i are the only ones left i'm
gonna win this no matter how much he
talks about light rail systems ooh you
should ride the one in akron by the way
very little noise oh my god enough about
light rails let's talk trams amusement
parks again
more cities adopted the music park
method oh put your hands on my ears i
just feel like you're having fun
hands are off we have a winner
me i'm on the stroller
oh i see what i did wrong it's okay come
on let's get you home excuse me
amy you can have the stroller for the
right price okay how much
amy santiago will you marry me no
you